пять вещей о которых нельзя никому
рассказывать Если вы не будете знать эти
правила то вашим планам суждено не
сбыться и вас всё время будет
преследовать неудачи хотите прожить
счастливую успешную и яркую жизнь
досмотрите это видео до конца и вы
поймёте то о чём Никогда и никому не
следует говорить есть вещи которые лучше
держать при себе мы часто слышим от
мудрых людей или из древних текстов что
молчание может быть настоящей силой Но
что это за вещи о которых не стоит
никому рассказывать Почему о них нельзя
никому говорить сегодня я хочу
поделиться с вами проверенной временем
мудростью которая касается того что
лучше всего оставлять в тайне первое о
чём не стоит распространяться и
рассказывать никому - Это ваши планы на
будущее если вы уже так делаете
Поставьте лайк этому видео этому есть
несколько причин Итак первая причина не
в самих планах а в том что ра вы
распоряжаетесь тем будущим которое не
принадлежит вам когда мы озвучиваем
планы мы думаем что всё в наших руках но
это же неправда на самом деле всё в
руках Всевышнего ни один из вас не может
мне гарантировать что доживёт до утра
Так о каких планах тогда можно говорить
Как говорится в Старой пословице Если
хочешь рассмешить Бога Расскажи ему о
своих планах Поэтому всегда если хотите
или планируете что-то сделать всегда
подчеркиваю всегда лучше Говорите Да с
Бог или надеюсь Бог даст нам осуществить
то-то и то-то Или говорите Иншалла
говорят мусульмане тогда вы не гнева
Бога Вторая причина в том что существует
зависть из глаз о которых к который ещё
никто не отменял ваши амбициозные планы
могут сглазить наука ещё не может это
объяснить но то что это есть Я думаю не
у кого не вызывает это сомнение поэтому
держите свои планы при
себе третья причина планы особенно
большие амбициозные планы они требуют
времени энергии и сосредоточенности
поэтому когда ыва о них до того как они
воплотились в жизнь вы рискуете потерять
свою мотивацию это кстати Доказано
наукой почему так
происходит смотрите Каждый раз когда вы
рассказываете о своих планах и получаете
похвалу или одобрение мозг воспринимает
это как своего рода награду и выделяет
гормон Дофамин это снижает стремление к
действиям вы как бы обманываете свой
мозг Он ведь считает что задача уже
выполнена Вы ведь уже получили свою дозу
дофамина признания это и есть причина
почему планы часто не
реализуются лучше действовать в тишине А
результат показать когда всё уже будет
готово Как говорится в Старой мудрой
поговорке или пословице Пусть за вас
говорят ваши дела а не слова А как же вы
спросите вы меня ведь вы же зачастую
публикуете свои
планы Да я иногда делаю Это но я обычно
это делаю Вот так я во-первых всегда
прошу Всевышнего помощи в осуществлении
своих планов и я публикую только планы
которые я собираюсь сделать для других
людей я не публикую своих личных планов
и вмест я планирую Я стараюсь говорить о
том что я хочу или к чему я стремлюсь
Поехали дальше второе о чём не стоит
рассказывать никому - это твои добрые
дела помогать людям - это знаете Великая
веь Когда у вас есть возможность
помогать людям в исламе даже говорится
что Верхняя рука то есть дающая рука
всегда лучше чем Нижняя но когда мы
начинаем говорить о своих благодеяния то
они теряют свою силу это перестаёт быть
чистым намерением В итоге люди могут
подумать что вы делаете добро ради
похвалы а не от чистого сердца в исламе
есть такое правило если человек тебя
отблагодарил в этой жизни то вы в
расчёте ваши благие дела Не не зачтут на
том свете или второе правило Ислама при
оказании
благотворительности левая рука не должна
ведать Что делает правая есть ещё старая
притча которая учит этому Однажды один
человек помогал бедным но никогда об
этом никому не рассказывал когда его
спросили почему он держит это в секрете
он ответил если это я расскажу то это
станет сделкой я дам чтобы получить
похвалу А я даю чтобы просто
помочь вот это настоя доброта Когда вы
делаете добро ради самого дела а не ради
признания поэтому не рассказывайте
никому о своих благих делах за
исключением случая когда ваше благое
дело может Стать примером или может
сподвигнуть других людей к совершению
добрых поступков Напишите в комментариях
к этому видео какие добрые дела вы
делали чтобы сподвигнуть других людей к
совершению добрых поступков третье о чём
не стоит никому рассказывать и
распространяться
Это ваши конфликты и проблемы в семье
никогда не рассказывайте о своих
семейных проблемах и конфликтах о
недостатках членов своей семьи семейные
конфликты - это то что лучше всего
решать внутри
семьи вмешивать посторонних людей в свои
личные дела Может только усугубить
ситуацию каждый человек имеет своё
мнение и Когда Вы начинаете делиться
этим своими проблемами конфликтами или
недостатками с другими людьми вы
рискуете ещ больше вернее не то что ещё
больше вы рискуете вообще полностью
разрушить свою семью К тому же люди
склонны судить других даже не понимая
всех
нюансов Когда вы рассказываете о
конфликтах в семье они могут создать
определённый образ ваших близких который
потом будет трудно изменить поэтому
Старайтесь решать внутренние вопросы в
семье сами без лишнего вмешательства со
стороны довольно часто я слышу истории
когда люди жалуются мне на то что их
родственники или близкие люди не
благодарны вы знаете это
распространённая проблема а в одном из
своих следующих видео Я обязательно
расскажу Почему люди становятся не
благодарными и как сделать так чтобы
люди были благодарными чтобы не
пропустить это видео обязательно
подпишитесь на мой канал и нажмите на
колокольчик
четвёртое о чём не стоит рассказывать
никому Это ваши доходы и финансовые
успехи говорить о деньгах и доходах -
это ещё одна тема Когда вы говорите не о
своих
в целом
обезличить о своих деньгах и своих
доходах не стоит об этом лучше молчать
Деньги любят тишину это как раз про это
деньги - это личное дело каждого
человека у всех людей разные способности
разные цели и разные
ценности люди просто по-разному
воспринимают деньги Поэтому Когда Вы
начинаете рассказывать о своих
финансовых успехах это может вызвать
зависть напряжение даже отноше Люде к
вам Кроме того не стоит забывать что
деньги - это инструмент который должен
служить вам а не наоборот
если вы делаете деньги Центральной Темой
ваших разговоров то они начинают
доминировать над вашей жизнью и это
начинает Кстати притягивать вам к вам
только тех людей для которых важны
только деньги а это как вы знаете Очень
чревато Лучше быть магнитом для людей с
правильными ценностями Поэтому лучше
держите свои деньги и свои финансовые
доходы при себе пятое о чём не стоит
распространяться - Это ваши личные цели
и духовные практики те кто занимается
личностным ростом или духовными
практиками знают что это очень интимная
тема ваши внутренние переживания цели и
практика это же ваш личный путь который
нельзя объяснить или передать словами
так вот когда вы делитесь своими
духовными поисками или методами с
другими это может лиш их силы и
значимости Почему Потому что духовные
переживания Уникальны для каждого
человека Когда вы объясняете пытаетесь
объяснить это кому-то то часто
встречаете непонимание или даже
скептицизм и это может вызвать сомнения
в вас
самих поэтому многие мудрецы говорят
духовный путь - это
тишина не пускайте посторонних в ваш
храм И кстати если вас интересует
какие-то алгоритмы инсайты и или мои
мысли по трансформации вашего бизнеса
или или вашей жизни У меня есть Telegram
канал где Я делюсь своими размышлениями
А на эту тему подписывайтесь на мой
Telegram канал ссылку на мой Telegram
канал я оставлю в описании к этому видео
эти пять вещей - это проверенная времене
мудрость которой руководствовались все
великие люди на протяжении веков не всё
в нашей жизни должно становиться
достоянием общественности молчание как
говорят это золото оставляя определённые
вещи при себе вы сохраняете свою энергию
фокус и внутреннюю силу поэтому помните
что истинная мудрость заключается не в
том что мы говорим а в том что мы умеем
хранить в себе действуйте и Работайте
над собой создавайте вокруг себя
атмосферу развития тогда результаты сами
начнут говорить за вас удачи вам на этом
пути